A mysterious new crater has been found in
Russia - but what is it?
How did it get there?
And what’s INSIDE of it?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you
weren’t already terrified enough of the
world around you, then listen to this - a
mysterious, massive crater has been discovered
in a remote area of Siberia, and nobody has
any idea what it is.
The crater is located in the Yamal region
of Siberia, commonly referred to as, “the
end of the world.”
And if that’s not creepy enough for you,
take a look at this video.
This was posted online last week, and many
assumed it was a hoax at first - but it’s
now been confirmed by Russian officials to
be real, and scientists are heading there
to figure out what exactly it is.
The crater is estimated to be about 260 feet
- or roughly 80 meters - wide, and from the
video, it appears to be infinitely deep, although
no one has figured out exactly how deep it
goes.
According to The Siberian Times, it’s located
near a forest, about 30 km away from Yamal’s
biggest gas field - which has prompted many
to theorize that it could be the result of
an underground gas explosion.
Other theories circulating right now, say
it could be a sinkhole, or perhaps the result
of a meteorite strike - although a spokesperson
from Russia’s Emergencies Ministry says
it’s definitely not either of those.
The leading theory is that it’s a natural
phenomenon known as a ‘pingo’ - potentially
caused by global warming.
A pingo is what happens when ice underneath
the ground melts, and pushes up the ground
from above.
The area surrounding the crater also happens
to contain the largest natural gas reservoir
in all of Russia, so if that ice contained
a substantial amount of gas, it would’ve
been released as the ice melted - eventually
causing an underground explosion.
This has been a pretty hot topic on the web
lately, so I’m sure we’ll be hearing more
about it in the coming days.
In the meantime, if you guys have any wacky
theories on what this giant crater might be
- leave in the comments below, and we can
all speculate together.
That’s it for me, but as always - thank
you guys for watching.